so you have a
viki tyso
so it is a drill
a micro drill of another micro drill
cable mazda
but inside the micro drill bike tyson
there's tiny tiny parts you can just
micro drilled
those parts okay
you have to have these parts
because they're the master key moves
they're the parts that open all the
other stuff that make it a micro drill
okay that you can take this these tiny
parts and use them in an abundance of
places okay
so
in tai nohenko
uh
it's not it's not any of this
you do inward spirals like everywhere so
why do
you encounter okay
uh you do rotation you you do a
spiraling geometry everywhere why do you
tie your ankle okay
um you reconcile ribs and energy
everywhere so why do there's no point
okay
the point that you have
is that you're going to we'll do it this
way
you're going to have multiple
repetitions
on
establishing a
single pivot point
that foot i'm lifting this foot so you
can see
the difference so you're going to do
you're leaving you're going to
transition
[Music]
and rotate
home
on that single pivot point
so if you're going to rotate
on double points do you see
there's no point that's not it you can't
use that anywhere okay
single pivot point you're going to use
everywhere okay
so
in
every single pivot point
you need me
single pivot point
boom
so you could buy you a drill a single
figure point
boom single pivot point
single pivot point
single point okay
eddie me you're doing joe dawn for a
reason okay
so in ikitai so
you're more of
an energy of resistance that i'm dealing
with okay
so if my hand is going up in the yin
yang world
what do you think my
center is doing
it's going down okay
so the micro drill
aspect you want
is
how to put your center
underneath his center
not how to push your center
straight back
you see
so
uh
any drill
so
i don't just go in
and go here
center goes on not just down
under your center okay if you're really
if you're much shorter than me i'm gonna
get really low so
under your center
here
you see that difference
so
under his center
and so same thing
you could micro drill under a center
under center
you could do that you probably should
okay
so make sure you have these two things
in your iv tie tyson for tai no henko
and he didn't
um
so i want to get under your center
that's true that's true
but what i do with that positioning is
not a free-for-all
so i still have to do the internal
aspect so your energy still has to go
through me and then in this case i have
a cochu projection
so it has to go through me twice it has
to hit the ground it has to come back
out okay
uh so i'm not gonna go over here and
that's that's not it okay
so it's going through me boom
of course i don't want to just push her
over here on this plane i'm getting
under her you see
under her
but this energy
[Music]
even if i want the other arm positioning
i have to be under her
not
even definitely not higher but it's
still
internal okay
now
some idiot comment
oh i don't like to see techniques done
on women
i guess you got no right to be trained
and feel your teacher's technique
um
but it brings up the point
that
i i'm not pushing on you okay
so
uh she goes
um
of course
it doesn't it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it does not mind
if you're doing it internally
do you get it
which is why
energetically
it's not
you don't have a penis and you do
okay
people are idiots
so don't be one
don't try to outpower someone
try to do the arts internal aspects okay
so yes under okay but what do i do once
i'm under i'm not just trying to lift
this thing from the bottom that's not it
that's wrong okay